honestly i don't care about my way
because people [ __ ] about it anyway
you're too small you're too big that
doesn't fit me
i am perfect the way i am selena gomez
has a message for all the body shamers
out there moral of the story
bye
on sunday the 29 year old actress called
out the haters who feel the need to
comment on her weight posting this tick
tock about a recent fast food order so i
be trying to stay skinny
but i went to jack in the box and i got
four tacos three egg rolls onion rings
and a spicy chips sandwich is anyone
else like starving all of a sudden oh
yeah oh my goodness yeah and listen if
anyone has a problem with selena
enjoying her life as she pleases she has
this to say i don't care about my way
because people [ __ ] about it anyway
you're too small you're too big that
doesn't fit mommy me
i am perfect the way i am in some moral
of the story
bye
i'm just so confident and comfortable
and i feel free more than i've ever felt
in my whole life i feel comfortable in
my skin you know and if the message
still wasn't clear cell followed up that
post lip syncing to rack city by tyga
[Music]
of course selena is all about doing what
she's got to do to protect her mental
health i like to choose to live my life
in a way where
i want to be weight free i think it is
important to to kind of go through your
life the way you wanted back in january
the former disney star opened up to
in-style magazine about social media
admitting that instagram is quote
dangerous for her adding that at one
point it became her whole world and she
never felt pretty enough so she decided
to quit i'm constantly somebody that
likes to grow and feel like all right
what could i be better at what could i
do better at where
where could my confidence be stronger
quote i created a system where i still
don't have my passwords and the
unnecessary hate and comparisons went
away once i put my phone down i'll have
moments where that weird feeling will
come back but now i have a much better
relationship with myself my personal
life and my family and my friends i'm
just i'm in a really happy place it's
been good and she elaborated about all
that earlier this month during a chat
with good morning america i haven't been
on the internet in four and a half years
it has changed my life completely i am
happier i am more present
i connect more with people it makes me
feel
normal it was the right decision for me
and all that self-love seems to be
paying off i am so excited
hi i'm selena gomez i'm steve martin
okay let's do it again i'm mark and
you're probably wondering when season
two of only murders in the building is
going to hit the airway i was wondering
that too i forgot
season two of her hit show only murders
in the building hits hulu on june 28th i
could barely keep a straight face just
hanging out with them it was so
wonderful and
i learned so much being around them
they're legends in their own right but
they've you know they're good people
humble funny kind and professional and
it was just the best and she's having a
ton of fun on tic tac just check out her
latest post shouting out her pal camila
cabello lip-syncing to her song
[Music]
[Music]
back on my bomb